Scott first met Jimmy Wu and the former
member of Shield turned FBI agent was
assigned to his case after he ran afoul
of the sokovia Accords though Scott's
ex-wife Maggie gets annoyed whenever
Jimmy comes barging in during Scott's
house arrest the Lawman and the
lawbreaker have a friendlier
relationship than their circumstances
would suggest Wu was fascinated by
Scott's close-up magic tricks a skill
Scott taught himself with the help of
online videos during his sentence as
Ant-Man and the WASP plays out Jimmy can
be seen watching the same videos and
trying out the same tricks when Scott's
sentences up Jimmy says he'll probably
have to arrest him again someday but he
also half-heartedly invites him to hang
out when Wu appears again in one
division he uses close-up magic to
introduce himself to Monica Rambo having
finally mastered Scott's routine Ant-Man
and the WASP quantumania pays off this
ongoing bit beautifully when Scott Lang
performs the same trick with a credit
card as an offer to pay for Wu's meal it
seems these one-time adversaries have
put the past behind them after all